Hello, you know this is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Today's presentation is on
What I titled brain drain. Oh, it's gonna catch you
But it's really how to remove the inflammation that's making you crazy
How to get the inflammation out of your brain a
Huge this is this is important
This one is one of two. This is really important because it's really the inflammation that is
Is causing the lack of
Brains ability
What part of my brain to communicate to the other part of the brain?
So if you read my book
You're crazy and other foolish things that doctors tell patients that need brain therapy
You'll understand that it is inflammation in the brain that blocks the pathways
So we're gonna use an example kind of throat as presentation since it's as easy as to talk about it
That your frontal lobe
The frontal lobe that part of the brain that's right behind your fore
Head there is really what makes us human
So we have a very large frontal lobe compared to other animals
And the frontal lobe is your part of your brain that gives you a reason
ability to reason think through things and your frontal lobe fires back on other
Deeper brain centers the type of fiery that happens from your frontal lobe to your deeper brain centers is called
Inhibitory signals. That means it inhibits it
So if you can think of your frontal lobe is really the parents of the brain
It's inhibiting the childish type of behavior that wants to come out of that
Instinctual mid-brain
So think of it that way and what blocks those pathways is
inflammation quite often so of course we could have
Specific damage from an injury, but usually it's even after a head trauma
It's the inflammation that blocks that pathway with Lyme disease with MS
It's the inflammation that's damaging those neural pathways either by eroding away the violent sheath or
Simply a space occupied lesion cause for the inflammation. That's just squeezy the neurons and decreasing its conductivity
So we're going to talk about how your body gets rid of waste and how we're going to drain that inflammation
So normally in your body you have what's called a lymphatic system and your lymphatic system. I like it at two
Kind of a storm sewer because it truly is an open-ended capillary system that drains the space between your cells
All your cells are tightly packed through your body
But there's a space in between them. So as each individual cell is making energy to do whatever it's that cell does
It gives off a waste. So like an exhaust and that exhaust gets
Dumped out into the extra cellular space the space between the cells and that it gradually makes its way back to that
Storm sewer that open-ended capillary that we call our lymphatic vessel and that drains back through lived nodes and lived nodes are
Our kind of accumulations of tissue that make
White blood cells and TH1 cytokines that will then kill any bacteria that's
flowed from the extracellular space through the lymph vessels
Because the lymph vessels eventually dump back into the blood stream and we would want like it a localized infection
Let's say I cut my hand and as that fluid is going to drain out of there. There might be a little bacteria
So it's going to it's going to go into the lymph system. It'll go through a lymph node and hopefully there'll be enough
Bacrophages and other white blood cells that will kill that bacteria. So I'm not
Causing a systemic infection of the rest of my body. So we have these open-ended capillaries. These
Lymph vessels these storm sewers all over our body that drain tissue waste if we damage an area like a swollen
Acle and we sprayed an acle or we cut ourselves or we just
Go through a lot of exercise that waste has to drain somewhere so it drains through that open-ended capillary system
Those you probably have heard your mother say at one time that you have swollen glands
Underneath your neck. Oh my goodness. She must be sick because he's got swollen glands. Those are actually swollen lymph nodes
Not clients. So that lymph node can hypertrophy if there is an infection
So the person's struggling with some with a strap infection. Let's say it is lymph nodes underneath this neck are
Swallowed there enlarged there actually increase in size. It's called a hypertrophy of the lymph node in order to make more white blood cells
to kill off the
Strap so you don't want to massage it to get to make it smaller and
Do things to try to make that lymph node smaller. That's a normal healthy reaction of that person's body to be able to find off infection
Just leave it alone
So all through the body we have these lymph nodes that make white blood cells that kill infections as that
Lymph fluid as that drainage fluid is going through the lymph system, and it's a wonderful system
So is this how we get rid of fluid in the brain?
So here's a picture of the lymphatic system of the brain. Ha ha, right? It doesn't exist
So for a long time, this is puzzled anatomists and physiologists. How does the brain drain?
There's no real, you know
proliferative
Lymphatic system in the brain. Yes, there is in the face the lymphatic vessels go up into the face, but not into the brain
So how does that get rid of waste in the brain? We have neurons
Those are cells that are functioning 24-7 whereas my muscle cells are, you know, sleeping eight hours of the day
But my neurons are firing all night long they're created waste
We have glial cells all these other little cells the astrocytes the
Bichro glial cells the oligodedrocytes of the brain that they're functioning in a fire-eated created waste
Where is it going? Well a few years back there was a group that studied this I
believe there were Dutch
scientists that discovered and named the lymphatic system of the brain and because what they found was a unique
function of the glial cells
So they named it the
Glimphatic system of the brain, and I thought that's a really cute name
So the Glimphatic system of the brain consists of a function of the glial cells now
We always do that their brain is is encased with a
Fluid that's called cerebral spinal fluid and there's some compartments in the brain that housed cerebral spinal fluid
And it was thought for years and years and years that the function of the cerebral spinal fluid was mainly to cool
the brain
So and then it was thought well that's maybe it has some nutrients in it and it's feed some nutrients
But there was kind of some if he doesn't what is it's cerebral spinal fluid is actually doing because it's encased
So is it getting into the brain?
How is it getting into the brain is that part of the washing part of the brain and until this study came out it was
It was a pretty gray area in neuroscience and how the cerebral spinal fluid worked
Well the study was interesting because they found that normally during the day time your cells of the brain are very tightly packed
Remember I said you have neurons and the neurons are the cells that carry information
So my frontal lobe communicates to my mid-brain through fiery to impulse past through a neuron down to the axon
It communicates through a sit-ups to another neuron and that's how my brain communicates and
Then there's the cells called the glial cells and they were named glial cells because they originally thought they were just the
Glue of the brain hence the name glial means glue so they thought these glial cells just kind of held the neurons in place
And they really didn't have a function
Well, that's really not true at all
We're found that the glial cells have just as much or maybe even a greater function than the neurons do the specific types of glial cells do different things the microglial
got really
Imported and immune function in the brain to help fight infections in the brain
The oligodendrocytes make up the myelin sheath that can be damaged
And if the myelin sheath is damaged like to MS in chronic Lybe and ALS then the neurons can't fire then we got all sorts of problems and
So these glial cells are very important in the brain
So what these researchers found is that during the day these glial cells are enlarged to their normal size and they're very tightly packed
So the brain is is is very tight. It's from an inside-out perspective of the brain
There's not a lot of space for motion
But when we sleep the glial cells actually shrink or contract they get smaller and in doing so
They're actually creating it as a modic pump that sucks cerebral spinal fluid through the brain
That literally just
Cleans the brain. So only in a sleep state
Do they see this? So where do we go into a sleep state?
Matter-fact, there was a lot of
Question and why do we have to sleep as humans?
Matter-fact, I remember years ago
Ten in seminars that they teach you if you can get down to functioning on just three to four hours of sleep in the
And the lecture was so proud that he could function on three or four hours of sleep that you could get so much more done of the day
And I tried to do that
I really tried my body that I could get by with a lot less sleep
I woke up at four o'clock every morning. It did study it. It was a wonderful time, but it wasn't
As you can see no, it's not real healthy for your brain
So if your brain can't wash away the chemical waste
Because you're not sleeping
Then you that chemical waste does damages neuron
So what you think you're gating that you're accomplishing more time during the day that you could get more worked out and study more
That's what I like to do during the day when I'm
So kind of worried, but that's my life
You're really losing because you're damaging neurons and glial cells because you're not able to
To wash away the waste. So while we sleep those glial cells shrink up and that fluid just washes through the
Open spaces in our brains literally gets scrubbed while we're sleeping
So that gentle flow of fluid through the brain just helps clean out toxins
Now how much more important does that's a that's how the normal healthy brain
A normal healthy brain is all we talked about so far a normal healthy brain is giving it off waste because it's
Functioning firing, creating energy all day long
Throwing waste into extracellular spaces that need to be washed out
How much more important is that to somebody who has suffered
From a traumatic brain injury has had a concussion
It's got Lyme disease has a chronic infection has damaged blood brain barrier
Etcetera, etcetera, etcetera, we're going to go way more adept on further
further presentations about that
But you can see how important sleep is just to a healthy person
That slide is really cool because it shows the artist who was just brilliant
showed that the
Left during the wake state that there's really no profusion of
Serval spinal fluid through the brain, but as soon as we sleep this profusion just washes through the brain and cleanses our brain
Just a beautiful picture of what's happening
So this mechanism of glial cell contraction and the corresponding
Rinseed of my brain tissue
Is really a function of a natural what's called an anti-adrenergic response in the brain that occurs when we sleep
so
Adrenergic means
From the sympathetic nervous system. So back up a little review
You have two nervous systems in your body your voluntary contract that muscle and your involuntary
My heart is beating while liver is detoxifying
All my organ function is my involuntary that's called your autonomic
Maybe you can think of automatic nervous system. You don't have to think about it
You don't have to think liver do your jobs bleed do this
It just doesn't automatically so that automatic automatic nervous system
Is separated to two pieces. They're really opposing pieces
First is your sympathetic nervous system, but your sympathetic is your fighter flight
I got to get this done under all his stress a bear is chasing me the police just pull me over
So that's your sympathetic it fires in a way to preserve a life in a stress situation
When my sympathetic nervous system fires my eyes
dilate my pupils dilate so I can see where I have to run the escape from this bear attacking me
My blood pressure increases my blood vessels
Constrict so my blood can get shunted very quickly to my legs and arms so I can run very fast away from this bear
All parasympathetic function shuts down
So they remember they're opposing so that's the sympathetic nervous system the parasympathetic it's a poser
controls digestion sexual function
detoxification immune system
Growth in replication immune system function as far as being able to fight off infection
Everything that you need for rest in relaxation is controlled by your parasympathetic nervous system
So an adrenergic response is a sympathetic response an anti-adrenergic response is a parasympathetic response and that's what's taking place while I sleep
So while I sleep I'm getting this parasympathetic response
It's shutting down the sympathetic and it's washing my brain
So it's really important because as we talk in later slides here how we can
How we can mimic this it's could be really helpful
So we can mimic this natural sleep time
anti-adrenergic response in the brain
By doing something so what would be stress reduction and we're going to talk about that in the
second half of this this presentation that will be next week
And there's some very specific supplementation that we could do to decrease my sympathetic nervous system response
Very similar to some of the things that we want to do with the person with high blood pressure
As a person with high blood pressure is it is it is it a chronic sympathetic state as well
So our take home from this is that we want to
definitely increase the length and quality of our sleep
Next week we're going to talk about some things you could do to help with that
And actually we have a whole presentation on how to do things to help with the length and quality or sleep
So stay tuned in the next couple weeks and we're going to get that
And then some specific nutrients that you can do to decrease the sympathetic response
And help you mimic that sleep time even during the day so you can help get some of that washy
All right, I hope you learned a lot and I don't think I went too fast this time
But if I did go back and listen to it again stay tuned for next week because we're going to want to talk about
Regarding this subject